and welcome to this special edition of
Hannity countdown to Iowa the 2024
presidential election it will kick off
in exactly one week from tonight we
should have full results from the
Republican Iowa caucus next Monday but
uh don't expect any numbers from
Democrats with a very complicated mail
and voting system and the reshuffling of
the democratic party's primary calendar
uh we won't get an official tally for
months of course barring a major trip in
Fall Biden will almost certainly be the
Democratic nominee the big question
tonight why Joe Biden's been a terrible
president his approval numbers show it
they're at record Low's his cabinet
doesn't even bother to keep him in the
loop on major issues uh no one even
bothered to tell your president Joey
Biden that his secretary of defense was
actually incapacitated in the ICU for
several days um just wondering out loud
what what if we had a national emergency
or some International crisis and we need
our secretary of defense we don't know
where he is now I guess it wasn't a
concern for the administration since
Biden pretty much sleeps eats and takes
vacations occasionally he'll travel
somewhere close to the White House for a
short speech delivered from a
teleprompter with giant font uh he's
frail he's weak he's incompetent he's so
frail that now his wife Dr Jill Biden is
helping the president manage his daily
schedule and this week Jill Biden is
actually sitting down for an upcoming
interview on Joe's behalf and now lately
more often than not the first lady also
has literally has to help her husband
you know very Dazed and Confused uh walk
off a stage after a rare speaking event
we saw this on Friday after Biden's big
I hate Donald Trump I'll repeat it for
the next 11 months campaign kickoff near
Valley Forge now the Biden campaign was
trying to use his historic location to
draw comparisons to George Washington
really instead Biden resembled a a
bitter angry aging well confused and
dazed politician desperately clinging to
power he has per usual demonized Maga
Republicans for the 4 million time
obsessed over January 6 for the fifth
million time and even bragged about
throwing certain riers in jail of course
he had nothing to but praise for the
violent looters and rioter and arsonists
and in some cases two dozen Americans
died and thousands of cops were injured
in the summer of 2020 remember those
were peaceful riots that his own vice
president tweeted out a bail fund link
for for the perpetrators in the
Minneapolis case after the police
precinct there was burned to the ground
that was so nice of her we didn't have a
commission for the 574 riots in the
summer of 2020 why didn't we have a
commission for that we had a couple of
dozen dead Americans we had billions of
property damage cops pelted with brick
bricks rocks bottles Molotov cocktails
2,000 plus cops injured no investigative
anything nothing no arrests we have all
the evidence why aren't we arresting
those people now sadly today more on the
same bitol in South Carolina where Biden
used the site of a horrific 2015 mass
shooting to further vilify his political
opponents now make no mistake the Biden
campaign all they have to sell is fear
hatred and Loathing that's all they have
they have nothing else to offer take a
look Trump's campaign is about him not
America not you Donald Trump's campaign
is obsessed with the past not the future
Trump's assault in democracy isn't just
part of his past it's what he's
promising for the future he's being
straightforward he's not hiding the ball
Trump's not concerned about your future
I promise
you Trump is now promising a full-scale
campaign of Revenge and retribution the
same movement
that throughout the mob the United
States capitalisn't just trying to
rewrite history January 6 they're trying
to determin to erase
history and your future Banning books
denying your right to vote and have it
counted destroying diversity equality
inclusion all across
America harboring hate and replacing
hope with anger and
resentment democracy in Peril Trump
magga Republicans January 6th abortion
identity politics fear-mongering that's
all you're going to hear from the
Democratic party and their surrogates
and their willing accomplishes in the
media mob from now until election day in
November Biden has given up on his fake
pledge to fight for the soul of our
nation instead he's looking to divide
and conquer he's actually adopted the
Eric H holder strategy of they go low
kick them that's his his style of
campaigning or at least that's what the
Democratic part's trying to do now Joe
barely knows what day of the week it
actually is and we'll spend most of the
upcoming year in his basement or in the
white house basement or on the beach
somewhere resting and relaxing but so
far it's not working uh for Joe Biden
voters remain angry at their president
look at these polls the president is
down in nearly every single swing state
in the country and now two of the
biggest Trump haters in America are
reportedly freaking out that would be
former president Barack Obama and former
First Lady Michelle Obama they
apparently are getting very very nervous
according to the Washington Post during
a meeting at the White House quote Obama
grew animated discussing the 2024
election and the former president uh
Donald Trump's potential return to power
scares him and meanwhile Michelle Obama
expressed her fears on a recent podcast
take a look for yourself going to happen
in this next election I am terrified
about what could possibly happen because
our leaders matter who we select who
speaks for us who holds that bully
pulpit it affects us in ways that
sometimes I think people take for
granted you know the fact that people
think that government ah you know is is
it does it really even do anything and
I'm like oh my God does government do
everything for us and we cannot take
this democracy for
granted and I took her at her word for
the first time in her adult life she
actually was proud of her country what
happened now the government does
everything for us really now the Obamas
are completely out of touch we know that
but they are right to worry about Joe
Biden's political chances the Biden
White House has mismanaged pretty much
everything the Afghanistan withdrawal
the disaster that is our border the
attacks in the Middle East war in Europe
Biden nomics inflation is there anything
that's going well are you better off
than you were four years ago what drives
elections peace and Prosperity okay well
the world's not so peaceful Joe Biden's
getting bullied by China Russia Iran and
seemingly everybody else and on
Prosperity 60% of our fellow Americans
are living paycheck to paycheck
Democrats have done great damage to the
Democratic process despite their
melodramatic you know pleas to save
democracy and their Nazi analogies
they're the ones ripping Republicans off
the ballot without any due process now
that's a pretty Innovative way if you
really want to save democracy and
they're the ones attempting to jail
their Chief political rival in an
election year again they don't care
about democracy this is a slogan this is
a political strategy all they really
want at the end of the day is power hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else